Guten Nachmittag, Freunde!
Welcome back to SCP Explained.
World War II is one of the most tragic periods
of recent history, and perhaps the defining
event of the 20th Century.
And not only was this conflict a horrifying
atrocity that led to the deaths of 75 million
soldiers and civilians, it was also a time
of immense weirdness.
The American Military created the “Ghost
Army”, a tactical deception unit that used
tactics as crazy as inflatable tanks and wooden
airfields to distract and confuse the Axis
powers.
They also temporarily renamed hamburgers “Liberty
Steaks” in some places in order to avoid
the German connotations of the original name.
The Polish military even gave an actual bear
the rank of Corporal, and this bear - named
Corporal Wojtek - became a decorated military
hero, but enough about SCP-5464, we’ve got
bigger fish - or, well, bears - to fry.
One party in this war had more than their
fair share of alleged World War II weirdness:
The Germans.
Nazi scientists were performing horrifying
and nonsensical experiments - from medical
experiments on prisoners to attempts to create
large and ridiculous weapons known as Wunderwaffe.
One of Hitler’s right-hand men, Heinrich
Himmler, took up residence in a castle where
he and his men allegedly performed odd occult
rituals, and even the Lebensborn, a deranged
eugenics experiment intended to produce a
huge stock of Aryan children from SS-member
fathers.
And if all of that seems certifiably insane
- which, for the record, it is - then the
stuff the SCP Foundation has been suppressing
will make your toes curl.
We’ve already covered the fact that even
Hitler himself, copied by Stalin with the
help of Sarkic wizards, is now classified
as SCP-2430 and held in containment by the
Foundation.
But really, that’s just the tip of the iceberg.
We can thank a shady group known as the Obskuracorps
for the creation or utilization of a lot of
these artifacts and entities.
As we discussed in our video on the Immortal
Hitler Clone, the Obskuracorps was Nazi Germany’s
answer to the SCP Foundation, though their
highly unethical methods were much more like
a racist version of the Chaos Insurgency.
This group of loyal occult thugs was charged
with hunting down any anomalous artifacts
that would give Germany the edge it needed
in the war effort.
Think the kind of guys going after the Ark
of the Covenant and the Holy Grail while trying
to kill Indiana Jones.
Of course, seeing as Germany still lost the
war in the end, they weren’t exactly the
best at their job.
But that doesn’t mean they don’t have
a long list of bizarre and often dangerous
anomalies to their name.
Starting with SCP-2367.
This is a device so infamous that not even
the SCP Foundation has been able to fully
suppress knowledge of its existence.
Popularly known as “Die Glocke”, meaning
“The Bell” in German, this device has
been a popular staple among time travel and
alien conspiracy theorists.
And those theorists honestly aren’t that
far from the truth.
The Bell is a spatial and temporal transportation
device created by the Germans during World
War II in hopes of teleporting spies, soldiers,
and equipment behind enemy lines.
And terrifyingly, the machine actually worked
and was able to transport multiple SS officers.
However, there is one detail that makes Die
Glocke a little less terrifying: Everything
they transport materializes several hundred
feet over the top of their intended destinations.
In the case of all transported SS Officers,
this meant that they appeared high in the
air and immediately fell to their doom like
Wile E. Coyote.
SS Officers hitting the ground at incredibly
high speeds is always a delightful mental
image.
As funny and incompetent as this is, there
is actually one major threat posed by SCP-2367.
The SCP Foundation raided a number of Obskura
strongholds during World War II as part of
an operation cal led Operation Hammer.
During one of their raids, a large group of
around 1400 German soldiers, along with a
huge number of large vehicles and pieces of
military equipment, fled via Die Glocke.
They all disappeared through the teleporter,
and according to all Foundation estimates,
they’re likely to manifest again in 2031.
They’ll rain down from the sky near Berlin,
crushing everything below under the weight
of their own vehicles and bodies.
A Mobile Task Force, nicknamed Himmler's Housekeepers,
has been mobilized to clear the area and reduce
all possible civilian fatalities when this
happens.
German engineering at its finest, right?
But hey, let’s give those mad Nazi inventors
another chance to prove themselves with a
second, even bigger Wunderwaffe designed by
Albert Speer, German Minister of Armaments
and War Production under Adolf Hitler.
It’s SCP-044, the biggest artillery weapon
ever created.
It’s a ginormous cannon, 251,000 kg, or
251 metric tonnes in weight, and so huge that
it required two freight locomotives at the
same time to transport it.
The Nazis were big fans of absurdly huge weapons,
whether they were cannons, giant planes, or
the world’s heaviest tanks - almost as though
they were compensating for something - but
there is one thing that makes 044 special
to the point of being anomalous: It can fire
literally anything.
When something is placed inside the firing
chamber of SCP-044, the weapon will transform
it into a powerful explosive payload, with
its explosive power being proportional to
the size of the objects placed inside.
Even crowds of people could be transformed
into deadly explosive rounds.
One of the largest objects that the Foundation
fired off was the Administrator’s diesel
pickup truck, weighing 8,900 kg.
How on earth did the Nazis ever lose with
a weapon like this on their side, right?
Well, much like so many of their other weapons,
it was a victim of their own greed: Weapons
this big just couldn’t be moved practically
and were easily routed by less powerful but
more maneuverable Allied weapons.
Next, we have another anomalous Nazi failure,
though this one was intended to give life
rather than take it for once.
The anomaly in question is SCP-2936, a secret
Nazi military and research base hidden in
the cold reaches of Antarctica.
The place has likely been abandoned by humans
since the 1950s, but there is one entity that
still rolls through the halls on rumbling
caterpillar tracks.
An advanced sentient robot nicknamed the Stahlmutter,
or Steel Mother, powered by a mysterious power
source shaped like an ambiguous glowing symbol
on its chest.
Who would have guessed that the Nazi design
sensibility was tacky?
The Stahlmutter is there to maintain the Glasgebärmuttern,
or glass wombs, where a number of desiccated
human fetuses are held.
The intention of this base was clear - much
like the Lebensborn project we mentioned at
the start of the video, this was a controlled
breeding program supported by the Nazi’s
deranged philosophy of eugenics.
But after the war, when the Nazis attending
the base presumably fled for their lives,
there was some kind of accident that destroyed
the seal of the glass wombs, allowing the
amniotic fluids to leak out and killing the
fetuses inside.
But, due to a malfunction, the Stahlmutter’s
diagnostics were way off, and it never realized
that its mission was futile.
When researchers attempted to inform the machine
of that fact, it simply replied:
“The children lie on the bottoms of their
Glasgebärmuttern.
They are unmoving, like the dead soldiers.
But the children are not soldiers, and the
children are not Untermenschen.
And the chemical, physical, and mechanical
parameters of the Glasgebärmuttern are all
at optimal values.
Therefore, the children are not dead.
The Stahlmutter loves the children always.
Good children will grow strong and brave and
wise.
The Stahlmutter loves the good children.”
The next anomaly wasn’t created by the Germans
or the Obskura, but it was utilized by them.
It’s SCP-3457, a collection of strange rituals,
artifacts, and workings known as the Rites
of Solomon.
If the correct artifacts are collected and
the rites are performed, the executors of
the ritual have the ability to control the
distribution of magic, or thaumaturgy, across
the globe.
Its Obskura’s plan to perform the rite,
and remove the ability to perform thaumaturgy
from anyone who wasn’t of Germanic descent,
giving them German magic supremacy.
This was the end of the infamous Seventh Occult
War, which was the major geopolitical event
that led to the formation of the Global Occult
Coalition, coinciding roughly with what we
civilians consider World War II.
Luckily, through a collaboration between the
SCP Foundation and the precursor to the Global
Occult Coalition, the Allied Occult Coalition,
Obskura were defeated before they could complete
the ritual and grant magical supremacy for
the Fatherland.
Since the defeat of Obskura in this pivotal
battle, organizations like the SCP Foundation,
the GOC, and others have sworn to keep the
different artifacts necessary to perform the
Rites of Solomon safe and secure.
Some are kept in public museums as part of
a global sting operation to catch remaining
members of Obskura, who hope to someday attempt
the dark ritual again.
Some of the items remain in the hands of scattered
Obskura remnants to this day.
Okay, so arcane historical rites are a little
complicated, let’s hop back to another wacky
Wunderwaffe to cleanse our palette.
Something like SCP-3721.
Remember when we said the Germans were kind
of obsessed with having the biggest, gaudiest
guns back during World War II?
They were also apparently ahead of their time
in this regard, as in 1943, they were able
to construct a fully operational orbital cannon
and an earthbound computer bank that allowed
them to operate its strikes remotely.
But, even scarier than a giant orbital cannon
controlled by the Nazis is a giant orbital
cannon that’s completely out of control.
That’s right: The computer on the ground
is autonomous and decides the best time to
make its strike by monitoring news broadcasts
of current events.
So if you feel like a day full of bad news
is unpleasant, just be grateful that it wasn’t
the day that activated the massive death satellite
looming up above.
Maybe the idea of the land being bombarded
by an orbital cannon freaks you out a little.
Understandable, really.
Maybe you’d prefer to flee to the water
for safety.
But you’re not safe from the Germans there,
either - and we’re not just talking about
them stealing your beach chairs while you’re
going for a swim.
We’re talking about SCP-4217, which was
once known as the Bismarck, which was a German
WW2 battleship before it was appropriated
by a giant cephalopod that not only has giant,
dangerous tentacles but also has the ability
to use all of the ship’s weapons against
you, too.
What will you think of next, Germany?
And finally, perhaps the strangest Obskura
Wunderwaffe of all: A dangerous semantic weapon
known as SCP-3878.
It’s a deadly, word-based, infectious cognitohazard
created in a single Patient Zero via a strict
regimen of psychotropic drugs, electroconvulsive
therapy, and at the conclusion of the program,
trepanation to create an extremely strong
anti-concept within the subject's mind.
When this person is activated with a trigger
stimuli, they will begin to spread the cognitohazard,
causing a lethal effect to anyone who doesn’t
speak the subject’s native language fluently.
The first infectee would have been German
if the plan came to fruition, so all but fluent
German speakers would have been killed by
the infection.
It’s a solid plan.
By which we mean, a Metal Gear Solid plan.
Incidentally, killing the victims of this
cognitohazard was never actually the plan,
they just hoped to erase other languages.
Though given that the Nazis weren’t exactly
people of high moral fiber, we’d be willing
to bet they were probably a-okay with killing
everyone who wasn’t a fluent speaker of
German anyway.
And there you have it - a taster plate of
the wackiest Wunderwaffe and the sinister
soldiers and scientists who made them a reality,
or at least tried to twist them to their own
gain.
It’s honestly lucky for all of us that the
Nazis during World War II were a gang of arrogant
and incompetent buffoons, because if that
weren’t the case, we’d probably be speaking
German right now.
Though if you like to live on the bright side,
at least we’d be safe from SCP-3878!
Now go check out “SCP-1461 - House of the
Worm” and “SCP-2430 - Immortal Hitler
Clone” for more terrifying wartime anomalies!